where are you today boss yeah man I'm in
Atlanta City Atlanta not no annex city
of New York there's a plant in the
Georgia and what are you doing I'm
actually down here working on a wolf
after project in conjunction with Oprah
Winfrey she's they've got the new great
drama drippy series it's about to get
started so today we're doing our first
table read so I'm super excited about
that how I do live called ambitions
ambitions ambitions look what do what do
you remember about that he misbehaves
what do you remember about that photo
shoot for that poster it was fun because
we had kids in it and every time you
have kids and you know a photo shoot or
anything you work on this always that
thing that she's really foreign cat you
know counting on and we had you know
kids trying to line up and stay alert
and one kids wiping boogers on a kid in
front of him and you know we had you
know beautiful beautiful Playboy bunny
that was played he was awesome and you
know just it was just a fun vibrant you
know colorful photo shoot that John
Cusack goes to put together I think it
was one of the very close creative ones
that he did out of all of them
but you look back were you able to
handle I mean I was you're a big deal
back then did it did it get out of hand
oh yeah absolutely it was like a tornado
I beg Li remember most of any of it it
just it just was like a like a freight
train that came right through the middle
of you know my consciousness and I never
really got a chance to just Center
myself and and just do what I love which
was playing football and that's partly
my ownership I have to take because I
allowed you know people around me to
take control of certain parts of my life
and you know you know tell me we're
gonna do this show we're gonna go over
it do this you know I was doing you know
the ten night children the middle of the
season which is you know nobody nobody
does stuff like that but you know when
your agents call them the coach and then
trying to get permission so that you can
fly down to LA to do
Carson show it's like you know toes you
probably know what what are you talking
about we're getting ready for the next
week so that's how that's how insane my
life was and I wish I had a little bit
more control and and I tell young kids
today give me this this blessing that
you have to play a pro sports or even
college sports is such a small window to
just focus solely on what that purpose
is and all the other you know extra
ancillary things just block that white
noise out and focus on what you're
supposed to be doing
what's the wild wild is your fame god
man I don't know I think the infamy part
of it was probably that t-shirt down and
down in the Orange Bowl and I you know
made that statement I shouldn't have
made at least on that stage and I felt
betrayed in a certain regard because of
the circumstances that led up to that
but you know that you know pulling into
you know New York to play the Jets and
looking on the on the marquee sign and
it was the Boz versus the Jets and I'm
all the guys in the bus you know looking
at me oh really
I thought out of control it was and I
wish I could have done some things but
you know partially as part of the things
that I was doing you know you know
saying the things that I said but that
was kind of what they wanted that came
in and they said hey we we need an
identity definition see I don't nobody
even knows we exist and quite frankly
when they pick me it's like I had to
scratch my head as supreme it's what
Washington they ever football team up
there realize that you know so but I've
become you know a big fan i watch them
one of my very exclusive teams that I
watched in the NFL when I do turn on on
Sunday and they're doing they're doing
pretty well and considering they've lost
a lot of their players but and we've
lost you know our great owner he just
passed away god bless him so but you
know I just it was just it was a blur
and I wish I had more time now wish it
had lasted longer and I and I wasn't
smart and I didn't listen to my body
when my body was telling me I'm breaking
down go get it fixed I tried to play to
the injury
and ended up destroying my destroying my
body there's that infamous collision
with you and Bo Jackson when's the last
time you cross paths with Bo Jackson
Lowen are actually great friends we
talked quite a bit we were actually
sitting in the car together we did a Kia
commercial a couple of years back I've
gone out and participated in his both
bikes Bama which I highly suggest
anybody go out and do that such a great
cause where you get on a bike you know
you're either going 30 miles or 65 miles
and of course I I bike all the time but
I said biking in the studio is not the
same as biking on a road so 30 or 60 s
come all the way in here 30 so I did the
60 and you know my tail felt it for a
couple of weeks after you know it was
for a great cause and but Bo and I you
know we're we've never been at odds
together I think we highly respect each
other as athletes and as humans
hey it's great to talk to you in short
notice love to have you talk football
well maybe you want to talk acting I
know
you're in a movie what men want that
comes out 2019 with taraji play hence it
wet so that's big-time stuff there this
is the opposite of the Mel Gibson movie
what women want that came out in 2001
Durst and it's hysterical it's very
funny that Tracy Morgan in there and
some cameos with Shaq and and Mark Cuban
immigrant hill and gistic there's a
great cast and everybody had so much fun
on it so yeah I'm really looking forward
to that coming up and I think it's good
to check in with you bonds thanks for
being available we appreciate your time
thank you Dad appreciate anytime
that's uh brian bosworth for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]